bien mes chers collègues nous allons
nous allons commencer
nous avons le plaisir ce matin
d'accueillir devant notre commission
monsieur Vincenzo Salvetti qui est très
important
puisque vous êtes directeur des
applications militaires du Commissariat
à l'énergie atomique et aux énergies
alternatives vous avez fait carrière du
reste au sein de la DGA puis du CEA
et donc on va parler de sujets qui sont
majeurs pour l'avenir de notre politique
de défense comme vous l'imaginez
je rappelle que le CEA a été créé en
1945 pour développer des applications
issues des sciences de l'atome dans le
domaine de la défense les applications
concernant les armes nucléaires que la
propulsion nucléaire navale il s'agit
fondamentalement de préserver de
développer et de garantir l'avenir de ce
qui constitue la clé de voûte de notre
système de défense alors Monsieur le
Directeur vous nous préciserez le rôle
du CEA dans le pilotage du nucléaire
français et plus particulièrement le
rôle des appliqués de la direction des
applications militaires et vous nous
direz si vous disposez des moyens qui
sont de quel moyen sont mises en oeuvre
dans le cas de la nouvelle LPM comment
travaillez-vous avec la DGA et
l'état-major des armées sur l'ensemble
de ces sujets
comme vous le savez le Sénat travail
depuis plusieurs semaines sur le projet
de loi de programmation militaire
2024-2030 que la Commission a adopté
mercredi dernier avec 171 amendements
nous l'examinerons en séance publique à
partir du 27 juin et j'aurai à la fin de
cette séance l'occasion de vous faire un
petit point sur les conversations qui
ont lieu en ce moment autour de cette
LPM dans ce contexte la question de la
dissuasion nucléaire est évidemment
particulièrement importante des moyens
tout à fait conséquents sont consacrés
au renouvellement des deux composantes
la complaisante maritime et la
composante aéroportée il en va en effet
de notre crédibilité technologique et
stratégique dans une période de grande
tension et de réactivation du discours
nucléaire de la part de la Russie mais
aussi de monter en puissance rapide de
capacité nucléaire de la Chine ces
questions sont évidemment fondamentales
alors vous pouvez nous apporter quelques
précisions sur les enjeux financiers car
en effet nous disposons d'assez peu
d'informations et c'est peu de dire sur
ce sujet mais il semble je dis bien il
semble qu'environ 12% des crédits de la
LPM 204 2024-2030 soit consacré à la
dissuasion vous direz comment c'était
fort et ventilé et comment il montra en
puissance
la dissuasion nucléaire a connu un
tournant en 1996 avec l'abandon de la
composante terrestre et la réalisation
nucléaires pour tester les matériels
vous avez donc recours à la simulation
pouvez-vous nous indiquer quelles sont
vos moyens dans ce domaine comment
fonctionne ces simulations quelles sont
les évolutions technologiques à venir
les moyens programmés sont-ils
suffisants pour rester à la pointe de la
technologie
enfin nous souhaiterions connaître votre
stratégie en matière de ressources
humaines pour préserver les savoir-faire
de pointe
le cadencement des programmes doit
permettre de moderniser nos outils en
tenant compte de l'évolution des
technologies mais il doit aussi
permettre de maintenir les compétences
de la filière nucléaire française alors
que l'on constate des difficultés de la
filière nucléaire civile avez-vous
vous-même des inquiétudes sur ce sujet
je vais donc que vous laisser vous
exprimer sur un propos liminaire puis je
donnerai la parole après à mes collègues
pour un échange de questions et réponses
je vous rappelle que cette audition est
captée diffusée en direct sur le site du
Sénat voilà Monsieur le Directeur vous
avez la parole
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs donc
j'ai articulé ma présentation autour de
différents points je vais je vais
rappeler les missions de la direction
des applications militaires du CEA en
préambule j'apporterai mon émission
était assez nombreuses j'ai préféré
focaliser mon intervention sur les armes
nucléaires qui reste la mission
historique de la dame depuis depuis sa
naissance et puis je finirai sur la
stratégie en jeu de la dame et je
logerai dans mon propos différentes
réponses normalement ça répond à vos
interrogations je rajouterai quelques
propos donc sur les sur les moyens
financiers et les ressources humaines
l'émission de la dame donc depuis 1958
donc c'est une vieille dame qui a 65 ans
cette année
nous sommes là pour piloter réussir les
programmes qui nous sont confiés par
l'État
la dame assume une responsabilité de
maîtrise d'ouvrage sur trois programmes
fondamentaux pour additionner française
le premier d'entre eux étant le donc les
armes nucléaires et sur les armes
nucléaires la dame est responsable de la
conception du développement de la
fabrication des armes et qu'elle met
ensuite à disposition des armées la dame
garantit lorsque la sûreté et la
fiabilité de fonctionnement de ces armes
pendant toute leur durée de vie jusqu'à
leur retrait de service une fois retiré
de service les armes sont démontées sur
un site militaire que sur la base
opérationnelle de l'île Longue pour les
têtes océaniques où le centre spécial
militaire de Valduc pour celle
aéroportée
et sous-ensembles qui résultent des
démontage sont ensuite démantelés sur
les centres d'âmes la doctrine française
ne prévoyant pas de conserver des arbres
retirés de service
complètement monté elles sont
systématiquement donc démontées et
démanteler
la deuxième mission fondamentale où nous
exerçons une mission de maîtrise
ouvrages c'est la propulsion nucléaire
vous en avez parlé donc sur la
propulsion nucléaire la dame pilote la
conception et la fabrication des
chaufferies nucléaires embarquées y
compris leur cœur nucléaire en
s'appuyant principalement sur deux
mètres devant industrielle technicatum
et naval group sans oublier bien sûr
framatum qui réalise des ébauches forgés
pour les grosses capacités des
chaufferies de nucléaires embarqués je
parlais de la cuve du réacteur et du
générateur de vapeur
et bien entendu framatoma sur aussi la
réalisation des pompes primaires de ces
réacteurs il faut pas oublier non plus
Orano qui nous fournit le combustible
sous la forme de poudre d'uranium
faiblement Richie le même taux est
utilisé dans les centrales EDF la
différence fondamentale entre les deux
est tant que ce le minerai duquel est
issu d'uranium faiblement Richie pour la
propulsion nucléaire est libre d'emploi
ce n'est pas le cas du côté EDF
et tout au long de la durée de vie des
la durée de service des chaufferies la
dame apporte une science technique à la
défense
bonjour monsieur Perrin
la troisième mission de maîtrise
d'ouvrage qui exerce la dame c'est sur
l'approvisionnement des matières
stratégiques nécessaires aux armes
nucléaires donc cette mission là pour
objectif de garantir la disponibilité
pour les armes et la propulsion
nucléaire donc je parlais du plutonium
de l'uranium pour les armes le tritium
également pour le fonctionnement de nos
armes modernes et pour les chaufferies
nucléaires je viens d'en parler de leur
uranium faiblement Richie si on fait un
zoom sur les matières nucléaires
nécessaires au fonctionnement des armes
nucléaires depuis l'arrêt des
usines de la vallée du Rhône donc
Pierrelatte pour l'uraniumothma Richie
en 1996 et Marcoule pour plutonium
arrêté en 1992 pour ces deux matériaux
de matières stratégiques nous sommes sur
un sur du recyclage puisque la France
ne fabrique plus de matières fissiles
tant pour les armes nucléaires que pour
la propulsion nucléaire le ceadam
travaille en interface direct avec la
défense plus particulièrement la l'état
major des armées dans sa division force
nucléaire la vision FN et la Direction
Générale pour l'Armement donc les unités
de management en charge des programmes
nucléaires
enfin la dame apporte son expertise à
l'état dans trois autres domaines sans
en être pour autant mettre d'ouvrage la
sécurité la non prolifération nucléaire
la défense conventionnelle et
la ministre des de la Défense de
l'époque donc Michel a lieu Marie nous a
rajouté une sixième mission qui porte
sur la valorisation de nos compétences
et de nos moyens au profit de la Défense
et de l'industrie en gros faire profiter
le reste de la communauté de ce que nous
avons développé au titre de la
dissuasion
j'en viens au deuxième point de mon
exposé pour exposer brièvement ce que ce
qu'est une arme nucléaire bien entendu
en restant dans un domaine non
confidentiel le principe de
fonctionnement du premièrement le
principe de fonctionnement d'une arme
nucléaire
schématiquement une arme nucléaire on
dit aussi tête nucléaire nucléaire tête
nucléaire c'est la même chose et
composer d'une enveloppe externe dans
laquelle se trouve une charge nucléaire
un bloc équipements gère le séquentiel
de fonctionnement de l'arme il est bien
entendu situé à proximité immédiate de
la charge au sein de l'enveloppe
l'enveloppe permet de garantir la
pénétration de la tête nucléaire et je
vais prendre le cale peut-être le plus
compliqué d'une tête océanique ça
signifie qu'une tête océanique pour
garantir sa pénétration elle doit être
furtive en cas de présence de défense à
BM bien sûr elle doit être durcie un
choc KBM et bien entendu il faut qu'on
assure ça rentre atmosphérique puisque
une vole le vol d'une tête océanique qui
est largement exo-atmosphérique donc à
un moment donné il faut qu'elle rentre
dans l'atmosphère
la charge nucléaire elle-même est
constituée de deux grandes deux grands
sous-ensemble une amorce un étage de
puissance un étage de puissance
thermonucléaire le fonctionnement de
cette charge nucléaire conduit au
dégagement de l'énergie nucléaire qui
est spécifié par la défense et une arme
nucléaire une autre manière de la
représenter c'est un formidable
amplificateur d'énergie si je compare le
l'énergie des délivré par l'arme par
rapport à l'énergie délivrée au
détonateur qui permet de mettre en
oeuvre l'arme on constate un facteur
d'amplification de l'ordre de 10
puissance 15 donc 1 million de milliards
de fois le facteur d'amplification et
tout ça dans une durée extrêmement
courte quelques dizaines de
microsecondes quelques dizaines de
millionième de seconde
au sein d'une arme nucléaire on a des
réactions de fission des réactions de
fusion nucléaires et
la mise en oeuvre de ces réactions en
fait se font contenu de la complexité et
compte tenu de la brièveté des
phénomènes sont des phénomènes à seuil
je prends un exemple simple amorce ne
délivrera pas les énergies requises si
la densité critique du plutonium n'est
pas atteinte au cours de son implosion
il faut donc suffisamment il faut donc
prendre des marges de conception pour
s'éloigner suffisamment des seuils de
fonctionnement ce qui se traduit par le
besoin par exemple si je pense exemple
là d'une masse de plutonium suffisante
sinon ça ne marche pas
je vous parlais maintenant d'un peu de
faire toucher du doigt un peu ce qui est
l'optimisation d'une tête nucléaire pour
venir ensuite au programme simulation
bien sûr alors le petit médiation d'une
tête nucléaire consiste notamment pour
délivrer l'énergie requise qui est quand
même bien direct avec les arbres
recherchés en un dimensionnement qui
vise à réduire son volume et sa masse
naturellement il faut qu'il filait cette
dette nucléaire sur garantissable
désormais sans essai nucléaire nouveau
je reviendrai sur ce propos là et vous
expliquer ce que l'on a fait depuis
l'arrêt des essais nucléaires
je continue mon propos dans un système
d'armes les armées le ceadam s'accordent
et c'est l'une des premières discussions
qu'on doit avoir ensemble sur les masses
alloués à la tête nucléaire et au
vecteurs peut-être nucléaire et vecteurs
formant ce qu'on appelle le missile
qu'il soit aéroporté ou balistique
pour la tête nucléaire l'optimisation de
sa charge donne plus de latitude dans la
définition de son enveloppe tout
particulièrement dans les matériaux qui
constituent son enveloppe puisque ces
matériaux portent les performances de
pénétration de la tête dont je parlais
avant
les défenses des pays que la France veut
dissuader sont de plus en plus
performantes cela conduit naturellement
un besoin d'accroissement des
performances de l'enveloppe qui portent
les ses performances là et une chiner
l'optimisation des charges nucléaires
facilite l'obtention des performances de
pénétration de la tête et de manière
plus globale l'optimisation d'une tête
nucléaire donne des marches de
conception pour le système norme global
donc pour les autres composantes du
système en particulier le vecteur
avec l'arrêt définitive des essais
nucléaires s'est posé la question de
comment apporter la garantie de
fonctionnement d'une charge nucléaire
par la simulation sans recourir je le
répète un essai nucléaire un nouvel
essai nucléaire l'idée de base que nous
avons développé que la dame a développé
a été de concevoir une charge dans les
marges de fonctionnement serait
suffisants pour couvrir en particulier
les intertitudes de l'outil numérique
donc des codes de simulation de quelque
part cette démarche a consister à des
optimiser la charge nucléaire ce nouveau
type de charge donc conçu par la dame a
été dénommée charges robuste le robuste
significance signifiant simplement une
robustesse par rapport au seuil de
fonctionnement donc c'est une robustesse
de marge de fonctionnement
ce concept a été testé avec succès lors
de la dernière campagne des
cellucléaires en 1996 enfin étalé sur 95
et 96 et l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles nous avons eu besoin de cette
dernière campagne c'était effectivement
la qualification de ces charges au bus
parce qu'on allait on les avait jamais
encore encore testé puis je le rappelle
donc le après les 6 derniers tirs donc
réalisé en 95 96 le président Chirac de
l'époque les actes définitivement
arrêtées
j'en viens au programme simulation donc
avant 1996 donc je le rappelle garantie
de sûreté fiabilité des armes étaient
démontré par les essais la France à mené
au total 210 essais nucléaires c'est
important j'y reviendrai un peu après ce
qui est important c'est le nombre le
domaine dans lequel la dame peut
garantir des changes nucléaires
désormais sans avoir recours à un nouvel
essai et celui dans lequel le code de
calcul sera prédictif
je prends deux je vais prendre l'exemple
de la tête nucléaire aéroportée donc il
était la première tête que nous avons
conçu garantie sans essai nucléaire
nouveau pour qu'on se voit garantir
cette tête le domaine était relativement
restreint autour des engins d'irobus
donc testés en janvier 96 or
intuitivement nous avons testé au cours
des six derniers essais on a testé on
arrêt on a on a alloué trois essais pour
qualifier ce qu'on appelle la charge
robuste comme le développement de l'atna
est arrivé lancement du développement de
cette et lancement réalisation de cette
tête comme on dit aujourd'hui
c'est a été prononcé au début des années
2000 peu de temps après la fin des
essais nucléaires le périmètre dans
lequel on a conçu la TNA était bien
entendu autour des trois charges robuste
que nous avons testé dans le Pacifique
les charges qui répondent désormais aux
besoins des futurs systèmes d'armes
doivent et devrontent à la ligne durée
être plus optimisés pour les raisons que
je disais tout à l'heure si on veut un
système d'armes globale qui soit
optimisé et qui répondent aux besoins
militaires il faut que nous-mêmes en
tant que concepteur des armes nucléaires
nous fassions des têtes nucléaires
optimisées
il faut donc étendre le domaine de
conception par rapport au domaine que
non que l'on a utilisé pour la Tène et
donc il faut
améliorer la prédiction de notre code de
calcul en réduisant particulier toutes
les inters les incertitudes de
simulation c'est l'objet c'est le
vraiment l'objet du programme simulation
ce programme remonte repose si on veut
être s'inscrire dans une démarche
d'amélioration continue de
l'optimisation de nos têtes ce programme
repose sur une démarche continue
d'amélioration de l'outil de simulation
et cette démarche scientifique consiste
à développer des modèles physiques de
plus en plus complexes à résoudre de
plus en plus finement les équations qui
régissent ce fonctionnement des têtes
nucléaires grâce à des calculateurs de
plus en plus puissants
le programme simulation s'appuie donc
sur des supercalculateurs au meilleur
niveau mondial que nous co-conscevons
avec la société Atos
développe avec eux le programme
simulation au s’appuie aussi sur la
réalisation de l'expérience
discriminante dite de laboratoire pour
valider ces simulations c'est des
mesures expérimentales obtenus sur de
grandes installations expérimentales de
physique comme les l'installation
franco-britannique de radiographie X qui
est situé sur le centre de Valduc donc
plateau de Langres ou sur le laser
mégajoul qui est situé sur le centre
ceadam du Cestas donc au sud de Bordeaux
bien entendu les expériences qui sont
réalisées dans ces deux grandes
installations sont totalement cohérentes
de la parole de la France qui a signé le
traité non pour les ferations et qui a
signé bien sûr le Traité d'interdiction
complète des essais nucléaires option 0
bien entendu on réalise des expériences
en ayant zéro dégagement d'énergie
nucléaire dans ces installations
le code des simulations ainsi amélioré
est ensuite confrontée aux résultats des
essais nucléaires passés et en partie je
vous parlais des 10 210 essais
nucléaires que la France a réalisé
dedans il y en a à peu près une
quarantaine de pourcents qui étaient
fortement instruentés
confronté nos résultats numériques
finalement résultat des essais
nucléaires passés nous permet d'évaluer
la précision globale de l'outil
numérique et en améliorant la précision
de cet outil le problème de simulation
offre un domaine de conception plus
large pour les charges nucléaires
futures et permettant de garantir des
charges de plus en plus optimisées et de
faciliter ainsi la conception des têtes
nucléaires plus performante et plus
optimisée comme nous le défense nous le
demande le ministère des armées
volontairement je ne parlerai pas
d'épurer des limges du LMJ dans mon
discours introductif j'y reviendrai si
vous avez des questions particulières
sur le sujet
venons-en 3e partie de mon exposé
stratégie en jeu de la dame la réussite
de nos missions repose sur une stratégie
centrée autour de 5 enjeux majeurs le
premier c'est d'honorer et préserver la
confiance de l'autorité politique
à chaque fois que la Cour des comptes
réalise un audit de la dame c'est le cas
environ tous les quatre à cinq ans elle
souligne la clarté de la gouvernance des
proies nucléaires de défense cette
gouvernance remonte au plus haut niveau
de l'État puisque le Conseil des
armements nucléaires auquel je participe
et présidé par le Président de la
République
l'oeuvre commune qui est une directive
relevant du Premier ministre décrit en
particulier le périmètre des missions
confié à la dame et les responsabilités
correspondantes
la dame réalise un reporting annuel pour
chacun des programmes qu'elle pilote
devant le comité mixte armée CE1 tel que
précisé dans l'oeuvre commune en termes
de sciences en termes de d'histoire le
la dame a été créée en 1958 nous avons
réalisé premier signe nucléaire en 1960
et le la première œuvre commune cette
directive du Premier ministre a été
signée en 1961 donc dans tout cela forme
un tout cohérent
l'étape ainsi mesurer à chaque étape la
porte de la donne de la dame à notre
système de dissuasion la trajectoire de
la dame trajectoire financière s'exprime
à travers un plan moyen long terme de 15
ans qui est présente en comité mix une
fois lent au mois de mars bien entendu
ce document est en total cohérence avec
la trajectoire à 30 ans qui figure dans
les dossiers du Conseil des armement
nucléaires et bien entendu cohérent de
la loi de programmation militaire dont
vous venez de parler
le pmlt est un document physique ou
financier qui exprime pour chaque
programme les besoins ressources
incluant les effectifs de la dame
nécessaire à la réalisation de ses
programmes au fil des années les
missions confiées ce Adam se sont
élargies comme je vous ai rappelé les
soumissions dont on est aujourd'hui
responsable alors que à la création de
la dame la dame avait une seule mission
s'est développe concevoir développer et
mettre à disposition des armes
nucléaires pour la force de dissuasion
cette élargissement de nos missions
témoigne de la confiance de l'État dans
ce Adam ce qui nous honore et bien
entendu nous engage
le deuxième enjeu disposé d'une
organisation optimisée pour maîtriser le
pilotage des programmes notre
organisation est matricielle avec
l'archétypulation l'articulation pardon
entre des directeurs d'objectifs qui
sont quelque part des grands directeurs
de programme j'ai un directeur des armes
nucléaires un directeur de la propulsion
nucléaire un directeur des matières
stratégiques un directeur de la non
prolifération gros j'ai un directeur
d'objectif ou directeur de programme à
la tête de chacune des missions au moins
les quatre premières
c'est directeurs d'objectifs portent la
responsabilité de maîtrise d'ouvrage des
programmes et les 5 directeurs de centre
de la dame sont responsables de leur
maîtrise d'oeuvre
la dame comprendre 500 comme je viens de
vous le dire plus un site particulier
qui s'appelle l'insertion nucléaire de
base secrète de la propulsion nucléaire
qui se trouve au cœur du centre du CEA
de Cadarache
le besoin de souveraineté qu'aux
substantielle à la mission à la
dissuasion nucléaire nous a conduit à
conserver en interne la maîtrise
d'oeuvre de nos programmes d'armes
nucléaires
ainsi 75% des des 5000 personnes
employées en contrat durant indéterminés
à la dame travail au profit des armes
nucléaires de la France sous pilotage
direct du directeur des armes nucléaires
[Musique]
chaque système de l'arbre fait l'objet
d'une véritable discussion entre le
directeur des armes nucléaires et le
directeur des applications militaires
pour qu'il finit nous décidions où
placer le curseur entre ce que la dame
conservant l'interne en interne et ce
qu'elle consend à sous-traiter
les critères liés cette décision
majeures ne sont pas infinies ils sont
très simples à expliquer il repose sur
des impératifs de souveraineté de
confiance et de confidentialité des
travaux que nous menons et bien entendu
des considérations liées à la non
prolifération nucléaire
dès lors nous conservons toute la partie
amont des programmes d'armes notamment
la conception et notre politique
industrielle est basée sur un
partenariat un partenariat étroit et
direct avec plusieurs milliers
d'entreprises du grand groupe à la PME
cette organisation évite les
sous-traitances en cascade et permet
ainsi un pilotage direct des entreprises
et une meilleure maîtrise des projets le
budget 2023 de la dame s'élève à 2,7
milliards en crédit de paiement dont
environ 15% représente la masse
salariale massalariale bien entendu et
charges sociales ce qu'on appelle RCS
le troisième enjeu de la dame est de
maintenir notre capacité adapter les
armes de la dissuasion à l'évolution du
contexte stratégique les défenses des
pays que la France veut dissuader
évoluent plus rapidement par le passé
ces évolutions portent sur les systèmes
de détection avancée radar et satellite
et bien entendu sur les intercepteurs
ABM danger brièvement rappelé
l'existence tout à l'heure pour
sécuriser le contrat de pénétration de
ses défenses ce qui signifie pour nous
furtissez furtivité durcissement
multiplicité des noms de tête hyper
vélocités de nos têtes nos armes
nucléaires doivent avoir une capacité
d'adaptation plus rapide qu'avant
c'est l'esprit de la démarche
incrémentale de la composante océanique
également en cohérence avec une approche
au plus juste besoin dans un contexte
budgétaire contraint
dans ce cas de la dame doit maximiser
les performances des têtes nucléaires
associées au système d'armes à l'horizon
l'air solucléaire du quatrième
génération donc la sn4g à l'horizon 2035
et du l51.4 qui va succéder au m51.3 à
l'horizon 2045
pardon
nous devons en parallèle explorer des
solutions rupture à plus long terme le
planeur hypersonique peut en être peu en
être une cela passe par exemple par le
développement technologique de nouveaux
matériaux les têtes nucléaires futures
Sega s'écarteront significativement des
références passées et nécessiteront un
niveau d'optimisation de plus important
le programme simulation est essentiel
car elle permet cette optimisation
en améliorant les outils utilisés par la
garantie des performances modèle
calculateur moyen expérimentaux c'est
une répétition et en maintenant les
compétences bien entendu de nos
concepteurs d'armes nucléaires cela me
permet de faire naturellement la
transition avec le quatrième enjeu qui
est la maîtrise du maintien et de la
souveraineté des compétences nécessaires
à nos programmes
la dame conserve depuis l'origine une
maîtrise de 21 pour les armes nucléaires
notre mission historique notre cœur de
métier les compétences requis sont
spécifiques et longues à acquérir je
prends l'exemple de d'un concepteur
d'armes le temps de formation est
environ 10 ans pour en faire un
concepteur chevronné
une gestion précise des emplois des
compétences est menées à la dame sur ces
métiers spécifiques la dame contribue
également à soutenir à dissu un tissu
industriel français au meilleur niveau
nécessaire à la réussite de ses
programmes
nous avons engagé et nous poursuivons un
plein d'attractivité pour attirer
valoriser fidéliser les talents et les
compétences clés à la réussite de nos
programmes je veille avec mon Comex à ce
que nous pratiquent managériales soient
également en accord avec les valeurs de
la dame sur lesquels nous recrutons et
nous fidélisons nos équipes je parlais
de l'engagement l'intégrité de
l'ambition l'accomplissement et l'esprit
d'équipe ces cinq valeurs et c'est pas
le dame qui a décidé de ces cinq valeurs
c'est un sondage à la base de la dame
qui a été réalisée en il y a à peu près
cinq ans où on a posé la question simple
pourquoi êtes-vous venu à la dame et
pourquoi il restait vous est-ce qu'il en
est sorti c'est ça pourquoi les gens
viennent chez nous parce qu'ils sont
engagés au service de la nation
l'intégrité morale fait partie de nos
valeurs sinon si on se ment on ne sait
plus où on est et l'ambition il en faut
pour relever les défis que nous avons à
réaliser
l'importance du maintien des compétences
pour pérenniser la diffusion nucléaire
française est également majeure dans le
domaine de la propulsion nucléaire
dans le choix présidentiel fin 2020
d'une propulsion nucléaire pour le futur
porte-avion la nécessité du maintien des
compétences très spécifiques à la
filière propulsion nucléaire a fortement
pesé je pourrais revenir dessus si vous
avez des questions sur le sujet car
c'est la propulsion nucléaire je le
rappelle qui permet l'invulnérabilité et
la dilution des snne dans l'océan
la continuité des projets de conception
et de fabrication des chaufferies nucins
embarqués est indispensable pour
entretenir et renouveler un vivier
l'architecte j'offrit embarqué et pour
pérenniser les compétences d'intégration
d'une chaufferie embarquée à la fois au
niveau de l'ingénierie et de la
conception et la conduite d'un chantier
de bâtiment en propulsion nucléaire
depuis 50 ans cette continuité de projet
est indispensable pour maintenir les
compétences des deux gros maîtres
d'hommes industriels que j'ai cité donc
naval Group et technicatum qui s'appuie
sur 200 PME PMI et pour lesquelles on a
fait le on a fait s'exercice là en
2020 donc quand on a discuté du mode de
propulsion du portail en nouvelle
génération et on le refait
périodiquement on se rend compte que ces
200 PME PMI qui accompagnent ces grands
maîtres d'oeuvre industriels en fait
pour elle on ne représente qu'un faible
pourcentage de leur chiffre d'affaires
le clin d'oeil sur cette affaire là et
c'est juste un constat à savoir c'est
que finalement on a un tissu industriel
sera propulsant l'éclair qu'on pourrait
qualifier de fragile puisqu'en ne
représente pas une très grande partie de
leur chiffre d'affaires le cinquième et
dernier enjeu de la dame c'est d'assurer
la crédibilité scientifique et technique
de la dame surtout depuis l'arrêt des
essais nucléaires
depuis que nous ne réalisons plus
d'essai alors à l'époque des essais
nucléaires c'était c'est relatif la
crédibilité était assez simple à
démontrer puisque nous réalisions 5 à 6
et ses parents qui étaient naturellement
entendu vu par tout le monde analysé
bien entendu et donc à partir de ce
moment-là la crédibilité était démontré
aujourd'hui notre crédibilité
scientifique et technique sur les armes
du client en particulier reste un enjeu
fort
comme je disais précédemment la démarche
continue de simulation nous permet de
maintenir notre capacité anticipation
d'innovation scientifique et
technologique afin de garantir
l'adaptation des armes nucléaires à
l'évolution du contexte stratégique le
programme simulation contribue aussi au
maintien de la crédibilité de la
dissuasion par des publications et des
colorants des collaborations
scientifiques bien entendu dans le
domaine non classifié domaine ouvert
qu'il permet sur des modèles théoriques
ou des expériences de physique ouvertes
ou parler tout à l'heure du laser
mégajoul
ou ne réalisions des des expériences
pour la communauté académique je vais y
revenir juste après en termes de
publication publie environ plusieurs
milliers 4000 à peu près de publications
scientifiques par an dans le domaine
ouvert bien sûr donc classifié et à peu
près 10% sont semus à des son semis à
des revues à comité de lecture donc dans
des grandes revues anglo-saxonnes comme
nature ou science par exemple
nous disposons 100 salariés à l'interne
qui sont habilités à diriger des
recherches et nous hébergeons permanence
200 doctorants et poste doctoraux et
nous avons bien entendu des coopérations
internationales dans le domaine ouvert
dans domaine non classifié en partie
lieu en particulier avec les États-Unis
donc dans le domaine du basic-fit
par le partage de ces moyens
expérimentaux comme les MJ dans le cadre
de la politique d'ouverture scientifique
voulue par Michel Alliot-Marie nous
consacrons 25 ans lutte 25% du temps
laser à la communauté académique
[Musique]
qui garantit l'adéquation des problèmes
de recherche scientifique que nous
menons pour répondre aux besoins du
programme simulation
la mission de valorisation de nos
compétences dans d'autres domaines de la
dissuasion
la décision de Michel Alliot-Marie
concours également à notre crédibilité
scientifique puisque nous réalisons
alors les travaux qu'on nous confie avec
le même degré d'excellence que dans
notre cœur de métier et par effet miroir
ça apporte la crédibilité scientifique
de ce que l'on fait dans le domaine de
la dissuasion
j'en ai fini avec mon propos liminaire
je pourrais répondre à vos questions une
simple donc les moyennes la LPM donc
c'est à peu près 12,5% de ce qui est
alloué dans ce qui est prévu dans la LPM
qui sont alloués à l'agrégat nucléaire
et dans cet agrégat nucléaire
suivant les annuités on a entre 30 et
35% de le pour conduire tous les
problèmes de la dame
et ils sont suffisants pour réaliser les
missions que l'on nous confie très bien
merci Monsieur le Directeur
étant pas vraiment spécialisé je suis
surpris de la quantité d'informations
non non
classifiés que vous donnez je pense que
vous le faites aux garanties qu'elles
sont donc classifiées parce que
j'imagine qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
sont en train d'écouter notre notre
conversation parce qu'il y a quand même
des renseignements que je pensais plus
plus confidentiel mais enfin alors
j'imagine j'imagine j'imagine mais je
pense que c'est mes collègues qui sont
pas habitués à tout ça sont quand on
interroge ici le ministre des états
majeurs sur ces sujets on a droit à
trois phrases donc je vous remercie en
tous les cas de nous avoir donné ces
précisions alors j'ai toute une liste de
collègues qui souhaitent préciser tel ou
tel point et on va commencer par Olivier
sigouletti
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le directeur pour votre
présentation la notion de dissuasion
demeure régulièrement associé à notion
de puissance d'un état et cette notion a
toujours structurée les relations
internationales même si elles ont
largement et très souvent contribués à
une mondialisation des risques majeurs
ma question est très simple des états
comme le Pakistan ou la Corée du Nord
annonce le développement d'armes de
faible puissance toujours dans une
logique de dissuasion est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire quelle est l'approche
du CEA et très concrètement pour nous
qui ne sont pas des techniciens notre
président vient de le rappeler vous
pouvez vous dire à quoi correspond la
notion de faible puissance merci
Monsieur directeur ce que je vous
propose ça allonge parfois les débats
mais si chacun se tient ses disciplines
c'est que vous répondiez au fur et à
mesure à chaque question mais il faut
vraiment que vous fassiez une réponse
assez assez courte parce que elle va
être très courte voilà c'est non la
réponse est non
la notion de faible puissance elle est
complètement relative quand on regarde
Hiroshima c'était une vingtaine de kilos
tonnes d'équivalent TNT dans 20 000
tonnes d'équivalent TNT les Russes sont
développées le laisser nucléaire le plus
puissant car à la Russie c'était 50
méconnes 50 millions de tonnes
d'équivalentes TNT la France a eu des
armes tactiques qui avaient des
puissances comprises en gros quelques
kilotonnes un peu moins de 10 8 kg à 23
kg alors est-ce que ce sont pour autant
des armes de faible énergie je pense pas
qu'on puisse dire on puisse pas parler
on ne peut pas parler de faible énergie
qu'en développe une telle énergie voilà
et la notion d'arme tactique une fois de
plus
juste une petite dégression la notion de
l'arme tactique c'est pas directement
lié à la puissance de l'arme c'est
surtout l'emploi de l'arme qui est
tactique
Michel gréaume dans le même rythme
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur selon un rapport de la
situation internationale de recherche
sur la paix de Stockholm le Cypri publié
il y a un an les arsenaux nucléaires
devraient augmenter au cours de la
prochaine décennie rompant ainsi avec le
mouvement de réduction des armes
nucléaires poste guerre froide parmi vos
missions celles qui m'interpelle c'est
celle dont votre mission et de
contribuer à la lutte contre la
prolifération nucléaire pourriez-vous me
décrire quels sont les mesures prises
sur ce point et en ce qui concerne
l'énergie nucléaire il semblerait que
l'uranium pourrait demain être remplacé
par le thorium métal argenté peu
radioactif 3 à 4 fois plus présent dans
notre environnement et qui présente
depuis plusieurs avantages par rapport
au nucléaire classique la Chine a achevé
la construction d'un réacteurs
expérimental au thorium à oui ouais à la
périphérie du désert de Gobi d'autres
types de réacteurs nucléaire dans des
pays comme les États-Unis l'Allemagne
des Pays-Bas les Royaume-Uni ont été
testés et en Inde il fait également
partie d'un programme nucléaire
pouvez-vous nous dire où en est la
France sur ce sujet des études menées
par le CNRS pour développer le projet
molten self fast réacteur excusez moi je
suis pas trop bien anglais sont-elles
terminées merci
personnellement si le nombre d'avenue
claires va augmenter ou pas dans les
prochaines décennies à la rigueur c'est
pas c'est pas de ni de ma volonté ni
dans mon pouvoir
lutte contre la prolifération du clair
je vous donne un exemple simple lorsque
la France a fait partie de la
trocadéciation du JCO et John
comprendovaction avec l'Iran en 2015 le
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères à l'époque dont Jean-Yves Le
Drian est accompagné par un directeur le
le directeur matière de non
prolifération de la dame qui était là
pour lui indiquer je vous rappelle le
contexte à l'époque les Américains
voulaient un accord à tout prix un
accord pour un accord la position de la
France a été sensiblement différente
puisqu'on a le lézian les décisions qui
a été qui ont été portées par la France
et proposition portée par la France on
savait dire telle mesure va retarder
l'Iran dans sa course au nucléaire de
tant de moi ça c'est fondamental donc
c'est un rôle d'expert ert technique la
dame at un rôle a un rôle uniquement
d'expert technique dedans
remplacer d'uranium par du thorium dans
un recteur nucléaire
je ne sais pas ce que les études sur le
sujet dans un réacteur civil sur un
réacteur de chaufferie nucléaire
embarqués ce qui prime c'est la
compacité de la chaufferie la chaudière
je rappelle le réacteur nucléaire donc
la compacité de ce réacteur c'est c'est
un exemple unique au monde elle passe
par une quantité quand même une quantité
d'énergie nécessaire pour que un le
bateau puisse naviguer pendant si
possible une dizaine d'années et avoir
la puissance suffisante si je prends
l'exemple du porte-avion pour catapulter
des avions le thorium n'a pas l'énergie
n'aura pas dans une chaufferie compacte
ne développera ne développera pas
l'énergie suffisante pour remplir cette
mission là par contre pour l'application
Racer civil je peux pas me prononcer sur
le sujet
victorium
et je ne suis pas spécialiste du royaume
non plus bon ça tombe bien il y en a pas
beaucoup ici autour de cette table allez
on continue parce que j'ai une longue
liste François Bonnot
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Directeur en février 2022 le CEA
franc-mateau mais naval group ont signé
une convention de recherche et
développement pour une durée de 6 ans
relative à la propulsion nucléaire
développement de connaissances dans les
domaines simulation des procédés la
composition chimique des ébauches et des
traitements thermiques doit contribuer
une meilleure maîtrise du cycle au
profit notamment des SNA et du
porte-avion de nouvelle générations les
recherches relatives aux partenariats
ont-elles déjà débuté et quelle est
votre retour d'expérience merci
alors c'est une convention effectivement
tripartite entre le CEA Framatome et
technique atomes elle est elle a débuté
bien entendu on se contente pas de
signer conventions derrière il y a des
il y a des travaux concrets qui se
déroulent et qui se déroule de manière
très correcte le l'objectif c'est
d'avoir la meilleure connaissance
possible des matériaux qui
qui sont impliqués dans la conception en
fabrication d'une chaufferie du cas
embarquée en particulier des cuves des
cuves de réacteurs donc on travaille
autour de ces matériaux là oui pour
accroître les connaissances de chacun
des trois partenaires
si je vais le guerrier
merci président
deux aspects la première le premier ça
concerne le fait qu'on fasse que de la
stimulation comment on peut faire en
terme de simulation plutôt comment
peut-on arriver finalement à
générer tous les cas possibles alors
qu'en fait on est sur du software et
quelle place peut avoir à ce moment-là
des outils comme ceux qu'on avait
développé que je pense en particulier au
monde qui est donc un navire de la
Marine nationale et qui a pour objectif
justement de mesurer les essais alors
s'il y a plus d'essai à quoi sert-il
d'une part la deuxième chose en béotien
aujourd'hui l'arme nucléaire c'est de la
dissuasion une dissuasion qui est peu
fonctionner que dans le moment où on
donne un ordre qui est l'ordre de
d'utiliser l'arme
j'imagine un scénario notre président de
la République se trouve dans un pays en
déplacement qui finalement dispose de
l'arme nucléaire et piège notre
président qui n'est plus en capacité à
ce moment-là de déclencher l'ordre et
utilise l'arme nucléaire contre la
France quelle est la capacité que nous
avons à ce moment-là de nous protéger
d'une situation de Soyons agressé par un
pays qui est dispose de l'arbre et qui
nous a finalement je sais pas coupé de
nos satellites pièges notre président
mis en place en fait tout un système
permettant plus d'utiliser l'arme
comment se protège-t-on alors pour cette
dernière question je vais je vais
beaucoup vous décevoir je n'y répondrai
pas
c'est pas du tout dans le périmètre de
responsabilité de la dame ce qui se
passe dans l'emploi c'est pas le
problème de la dame c'est le premier du
président et du chef d'état-major des
arbres
pour la question sur les essais alors la
simulation j'ai quand elle a été décidée
donc en 4 alors le programme simulation
ça a été défini à partir des années 92 à
partir du moratoire sur les essais
nucléaires et il a vraiment pris corps
en 96 à l'arrêt des cellulaire on a
quand même eu 4 à 5 ans pour s'y
préparer et le programme simulation
était uniquement destiné à garantir la
fonction énergie et sur tes nucléaires
de la demeure donc c'est la seule
performance qu'on ne saura plus essayer
réaliser en essai grandeur nature j'ai
aucun regret sur la décès nucléaire au
contraire les expériences et le
programme civilisation nous permettra
dans la durée d'optimiser nos armes et
surtout avec des installations comme le
laser méga joue les pure on réalise des
expériences extrêmement discriminantes
pour nos codes de simulation et qui nous
permettent en particulier de faire des
la chasse un peu à des compensations
d'erreurs dans entre les tous les
phénomènes évidemment qui s'imbriquent
dans le fonctionnement d'une arme
lorsqu'on faisait des essais nucléaires
c'était des essais globaux et quand on
fait un essai global en fait on ne sait
pas discriminer chacune des phases de
fonctionnement et finalement il peut
dans le fonctionnement global peuvent se
nicher des compensations d'erreurs et
finalement qui donne le bon résultat
donc je pense qu'on est on a alors pour
compléter la question j'ai dit qu'à
partir de 2010 on avait été tendu une
démarche de type simulation tout est
performances de l'arme dont en
particulier la fonction pénétration ou
portée
bien entendu on continue à réaliser des
essais en vol mais on ne réalise pas
d'effets spécifiques pour les têtes
nucléaires on profite des essais de
développement missiles balistique ou
d'ailleurs aéroportée ou des tirs
d'acceptation lorsqu'un sous-marin sort
d'arrêt technique majeur pour
positionner en partie haute donc un
objet un objet représentatif d'une tête
mais qui est une maquette ça nous permet
d'avoir des données supplémentaires sur
typiquement les performances de rentrée
de précision ou autre voilà on se refuse
pas de faire des essais en vol à cause
de ça au même titre que sur les la
performance énergie on conserve la
possibilité de faire des essents
laboratoires qui nous permettent d'avoir
des données supplémentaires sans aller
bien entendu jusqu'au dégagement
d'énergie nucléaire
merci merci évitons effectivement de
poser des questions auxquelles vous ne
pouvez pas répondre parce qu'il y a
quand même une dimension politique
extrêmement sensible pour lequel
directeur de la dame n'est pas
opérationnelle Alain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Directeur
je connais bien CEA puisque je suis un
peu un enfant du CA j'étais maire de
salive pendant 18 ans
j'ai appris à nager dans la piscine de
Valduc je voulais simplement vous poser
la question de savoir
c'est important de nager en eaux
troubles
de savoir où en est cet accord
magnifique et l'accord
franco-britannique qui a été signé par
le président Nicolas Sarkozy
en 2008 et
[Musique]
Valduc le CEA de Valduc qui est sur ma
commune la commune de salive une commune
de 250 habitants ou 1300 personnes
travaillent
où sont nés savoir quel est
l'implication quel est le niveau actuel
parce qu'il y a eu des financements de
mi il y a beaucoup d'infrastructures qui
sont créés et qui sont en devenir savoir
où s'en est donc Val Duke est intéressé
comme le barbe à Bordeaux donc
la dissuasion militaire est très
intéressée et deuxième chose j'aimerais
un vieux un vœu pieux parce que j'ai
l'impression que le CEA une entreprise
doit s'intéresser à son emprise
territoriale et le CEA de Valduc 800
hectares sur ma commune est un peu
comment dire
dans un camp retranché et il y a un
manque d'implication vis-à-vis de
l'extérieur qui est très ressenti sur ce
territoire qui est un territoire
défavorisé puisque nous avons 6
habitants kilomètre carré c'est le
désert côte d'Orient donc il y a un
manque d'application puisque la moitié
des travailleurs habitent à Dijon à 50
km et
30% de l'autre moitié habite à 25 km à
Is-sur-Tille donc très peu de gens
vivent sur le territoire actuellement
le visage et les villages alentours sont
intéressés par les justement les
ressortissants anglais qui qui aiment la
campagne ils vivent sur le territoire
donc j'aimerais que le CEA de Valduc et
c'est si mon vœu monsieur je connaissais
vos prédécesseurs s'intéressent plus et
il y a un symbole par exemple vous avez
changé de directeur j'ai connu François
Hugo pendant des années et vous avez
changé de directeur je n'ai même pas été
au courant
un principe mais c'est important que
quelqu'un qui a été si près du COA de
Valduc j'étais président de la Civa
c'est à dire en tant que radiologue
compétent en radioprotection j'ai un peu
rassuré les gens sur l'impact
environnemental d'un centre qui produit
du trium donc j'aimerais que le CEA
s'implique beaucoup plus sur le
territoire merci
alors beaucoup de questions dans votre
propos
traditionnellement lorsqu'on change
directement au moins la dame il y a une
cérémonie qui est organisée par le dames
effectivement où on dit au revoir aux
partants et on dit bonjour à la rivan et
on invite toutes les tous les maires
élus locaux le chemin directeur s'est
effectué dans cette période triste pour
tout le monde qui s'appelle le covid et
donc je n'ai pas fait de cérémonie pour
le changement de directeur entre
François buvot et Marianne sécheresse en
revanche je prends pour moi le fait
quand vous êtes pas informé j'aurais
parfaitement pu écrire un courrier tous
les maires de des environs c'est une
erreur de ma part c'est un oubli de ma
part ou une erreur de ma part simplement
comment
non mais on aurait pu on aurait pu
écrire aux élus locaux
le centre de Valduc on applique le
principe simple vivront bien vivons
caché le on ne peut pas sur des centres
d'âme comme celui de en particulier
faire trop de publicités autour de nous
c'est si j'ai bien compris votre
question comment
ouais mais l'implication territoriale le
salarié en fait comme vous le dites
ouais c'est de l'ordre de 50% qui est à
Dijon essentiellement les cadres ils
surtille il y en a un petit peu et puis
30% et puis effectivement le reste est
réparti dans les visages aux alentours
mais là on n'a pas de comment dire on ne
peut pas inciter encore moi aujourd'hui
qu'hier nos salariés habiter à salive à
échalots à molois je connais bien
l'argent quand même je m'achille qui
travaille au CO2 Valduc donc elle elle
habite niais sur Tignes value qu'elle
habite à jumeaux
voilà c'est un beau petit village si on
en vient aux choses plus sérieuses si je
peux l'exprimer ainsi alors le l'accord
entre le brillant Sarkozy et David
Cameron n'a pas été signé en 2008 et a
été signé en novembre 2010 en parallèle
au traité de défense qui s'appelle le
traité de lancastera House et un traité
particulier s'appelle le traité de ta
test et qui vise à partager deux
installations en fait nucléaires une au
Royaume-Uni en France bon c'est le
Royaume-Uni était une installation
mineure si on y fait de R&D il y a pas
de matière nucléaire engagée etc c'est
si on regarde le poids respectif des
deux installations il y en a une qui est
entre 800 et un milliard 800 millions et
un milliards d'euros c'est celle de
Valduc c'est avec le Royaume-Uni c'est
50 millions d'euros de coûts revient on
sait pas tout à fait les mêmes
proportions donc celle qui est à Valduc
et c'est peut-être là que naît la
confusion c'est le projet épure et il a
été lancé par la France effectivement en
conseil des armements nucléaires en 2008
par le président Sarkozy et au titre du
traité de l'anglais sera au titre du
traité de l'esprit en application du
traité de l'encaisseur house ils ont
partagé cette installation dorénavant
avec les Britanniques donc
l'installation a été mise en service en
2014 avec une première configuration
avec un axe radio graphique donc la
première phase ce projet a été 100%
française totalement financée par la
France et les Britanniques nous ont
rejoints pour la deuxième phase et
aujourd'hui à l'heure où je vous parle
le projet le projet est quasiment achevé
on a le deuxième axe radiographique qui
est en service puisqu'il était prévu
d'en avoir trois et le troisième qui est
de responsabilité britannique devrait
être mise en service à la fin de l'année
donc on aura une installation totalement
opérationnelle elle l'est déjà
totalement opérationnelle aujourd'hui
avec un axe radiographique et on a
réalisé plus de 10 essais de depuis que
l'installation a été mise en service en
merci avec les Britanniques se passent
bien ce qui explique les Britanniques
qui habitent autour de Valduc merci bien
andriol
merci Président Monsieur le Directeur
dans de nos différents discussions dans
le cadre de la loi de programmation
militaire nous avons évoqué plusieurs
fois la possibilité de prolonger la
durée de vie du porte-avion Charles de
Gaulle qui dépend comme vous le savez de
la qualité mécanique de sécu alors ma
question c'est quelles sont les études
de mener dans ce domaine quelles sont
les chances d'aboutir et quelles sont
les contraintes qui seraient associées
je vous remercie
le portillon de Charles de Gaulle dans
sa dû normalement retirer de service en
et c'est ce qui pilote le calendrier du
porte-avion nouvelle génération première
sortie à la mer en 2036 et première et
donc finalement mise en service en 2038
au remplaçant le portrait de Gaulle donc
le
l'avis d'un bâtiment propulsant
nucléaire le portrait en Charles de
Gaulle par exemple érythmé par son appel
des arrêts techniques majeures le
prochain arrêt technique majeur du
porte-avion aura lieu en 2027 il
débutera en avril 27 et dura à peu près
entre 18 et 24 mois le c'est lors de cet
arrêt technique majeur parce que là pour
le coup la qualité le vieillissement des
acides de cuve d'un réacteur comme le la
kk15 qui équipe le portail en Charles de
Gaulle on ne peut pas simuler avec la
connaissance que l'on a aujourd'hui du
vieillissement de ces matériaux on ne
peut pas simuler son vieillissement
et donc le juge de paix ça sera le
résultat de les examens qui vont être
réalisés à l'arrêt technique majeure de
qui va s'étaler entre 27 et 29 et là on
pourra dire est-ce qu'on peut prolonger
la durée de vie du porte-avion ou pas la
question qui se posera à l'heure si on
veut prolonger alors c'est que la durée
de vie aujourd'hui d'un cœur qui est
pied qui équipe le porte-avion les cœurs
de chaufferie qui équipent le
porte-avions en général sont les cœurs
les plus sollicités puisque le de par
l'emploi opérationnel du porte-avion
donc si on veut prolonger le
porte-avions au-delà de sa durée de vie
si prévisionnel si la cuve le permet ça
impliquera qu'on change les deux cœurs
si un cœur par chaufferait nucléaire et
donc là ça impliquera des d'autres
considérations regarde comment on peut
fabriquer un deux coeur supplémentaire
dans le planning de fabrication de
docker on a un outil de dissuasion en
particulier sur la propulsion nucléaire
qui est calé au juste besoin c'est à
dire qu'il nous faut en gros un cœur par
an fabriquez un cœur par an donc s'il
faut que j'en rajoute de ils sont
fabriqués à cadrage donc sous
commandement de la dame s'il faut qu'on
rajoute deux cœurs à un moment donné il
va falloir pousser autre chose voilà
mais sinon rien n'est impossible sur le
sujet par contre le juge de paix c'est
pas avant 2027 donc le résultat des
expertises on va dire fin 2027
la même question a été posée à l'amiral
Vendée qui a évoqué le coup de plus d'un
milliard pour cette opération
Ludovic est
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur mes chers collègues ce
directeur vous avez rappelé dans vos
propos que la France avait fait le choix
de ne plus produire de ces matières
ficelles notamment le plutonium en 92 et
puis l'uranium hautement enrichi depuis
96 elle a également fait le choix comme
vous le savez de ne pas donner de
successeur à Phoenix et super Phoenix en
nous donnant pas suite au projet Astrid
les fameux réacteurs de 4e génération ma
question est la suivante le fait de
renoncer au recyclage infini du
combustible d'une part couplé au fait
que l'uranium bénéficie d'un cours
relativement bas et donc permettent à la
France de s'approvisionner et
relativement facilement n'entraîne-t-il
pas notre pays dans une sorte de
dépendance aux matières ficile à l'heure
où la souveraineté est devenue le maître
mot dans de nombreux domaines à fortiori
dans le domaine stratégique et en
complément de cette première question je
me demandais si dans les années à venir
si un changement de paradigme venait à
s'opérer en matière d'approvisionnement
nous pourrons bien évidemment nous
appuyer sur les travaux d'Astrid et
peut-être aussi sur notre coopération
que le Japon en la matière me
semble-t-il mais aurons je me suis gardé
les compétences dans ce domaine
extrêmement spécialisé
alors votre question est à cheval sur
la dame certes mais beaucoup le CEA le
reste du CEVA parce que le CEVA civil on
a arrêté la production de la
diversificile pour les armes nucléaires
donc ça clairement on en fabrique plus
et vous pouvez aller régulièrement les
membres de la commission lorsqu'on
réunit une conférence du TNP vont
visiter ils l'ont fait encore cette
année peuvent constater que les
installations non seulement étaient
arrêtées ont été démantelés donc
aujourd'hui c'est clair c'est définitif
Phénix superhénique Astrid ça c'est
vraiment pas dans ma gamelle
on s'approvisionnement d'uranium
faiblement Richie ce qui est vrai alors
pour fixer ordre de grandeur le besoin
militaire en uranium faiblement Richie
pour la propulsion nucléaire ou le
réacteur des saters qu'on a à Cadarache
ça représente 1% du besoin total de la
France en l'uranium faiblement ici les
autres 99% étant EDF
nous on a besoin d'un pour cent de tout
ça donc 1% de tout ça aujourd'hui le
lorsqu'on change les Lakers nucléaires
en fin de vie donc je vais dit c'était
10 ans pour le porte-avion c'est 10 ans
pour sous-marin nucléaire d'attaque et
c'est plus long c'est plus long pour le
SNLE on peut les garder 20 ans parce que
le SNLE sollicite beaucoup moins c'est
que
et donc une fois que ces coeurs sont
déchargés en fait ils sont mis à
refroidir dans des piscines dans
l'attente d'une solution
ultérieure que ce qui sera de
l'entreposage à sec ou du recyclage pour
le reste je peux pas parler de Phoenix
je peux pas parler de ce que fait de F
une ce que fait pas EDF c'est pas le
c'est vraiment pas dans mon périmètre de
responsabilité et je au delà de
commettre l'impair de répondre je fais
pas les connaissances suffisantes pour y
répondre
sur les compétences nucléaires
militaires je n'ai pas d'inquiétude
puisque c'est on en est responsable sur
les compétences éclaircie ville suffit
d'y lire la presse et pas mal de gens
sexuels s'expriment depuis l'annonce des
des six EPR 2 et les 8 éventuellement en
plus mais clairement c'est une filière
qu'il faut remonter
parce qu'elle a Lisa
président merci beaucoup mais pour
gagner du temps je retire ma question
c'est exactement la même non mais c'est
parfait souci partagé donc merci pour
votre réponse monsieur le directeur
excellent Pascal Cédric Perrin pareil
non non je suis désolé de décevoir le
président le directeur merci merci pour
vos propos un peu abrute parfois mais on
a l'occasion avec Hélène comme moi de
vous voir régulièrement donc d'en parler
donc mais j'ai quelques questions
complémentaires il y en a une qui m'est
venue à l'esprit quand vous avez parlé
du traité de nos proliférations et de
l'interdiction des essais c'est consiste
à savoir un petit peu quel est la
capacité des pays dotés et même non
dotés de faire aujourd'hui des tests de
simulation et d'essai enfin de tests
sans essai pour pouvoir monter au niveau
parce que nous on a quand même une
histoire
longue soit dissuasion donc des
capacités techniques je pense qu'on a
créé au fil du temps aujourd'hui comment
est-ce qu'on est incapable dans un pays
où on a moins d'expérience de pouvoir
faire des essais qui soient des essais
non non réel et la deuxième question
peut-être que vous pourriez pour
répondre ou pas je ne sais pas mais vous
me le direz ça concerne la
délocalisation des moteurs Vinci
d'Ariane 6 de Vernon vers l'Allemagne
qui a été annoncé en 2021 le moteur
réaluma détache supérieur du lanceur la
question elle est simple est-ce que
Monsieur le Directeur en 2035 lorsqu'on
sera obligé d'aller ne sera-t-on pas
obligé d'aller demander aux Allemands je
peux un peu l'accord de cool
l'autorisation de mettre un moteur sur
le
51-4 est-ce que cette décision de les
localisation n'a pas des conséquences
quand même dommageables sur notre
capacité demain à mettre un moteur sur
nos
missiles merci beaucoup
capacité des pays dotés donc clairement
nous on a développé ce programme
simulation qui est adossé comme vous
l'aurez compris à la fois sur 210 de ces
nucléaires du passé qui nous permet à la
fin d'avoir la meilleure évaluation
possible du niveau de confiance donc de
l'incertitude de l'outil numérique
et puis bien entendu des experts des
grands instruments les supercalculateurs
le laser un mégajoul et pur si on
regarde ce que font les autres pays
dotés les États-Unis ont un laser qui
est équivalent aux notes c'est national
edition facility qui est à liver mort en
Californie ils ont des installations
avec des machines radiophiques l'eau
salamos cite du Nevada ils ont ces types
de machines là les brittes dépendent des
Américains donc ils ont pas avoir toutes
ces installations là et puis pour les
Chinois on n'a aucun contact chez Julie
chinois et avec les russes depuis 2014
on a un plus long plus au moment on a
arrêté nos contacts avec les Russes sur
décision de l'Élysée
comment ils avaient dans leur carton de
réaliser un laser qui serait équivalent
laser mégajoul ou au NIF américain et
des machines radiographiques qu'ils en
avaient puisqu'on le savait voilà donc
ils ont à peu près les après en termes
d'essai nucléaires les années les
États-Unis en ont réalisé 1051 et la
Russie l'Union soviétique pardon un peu
plus de 700 alors il y a un fait quand
même qui est majeur dans votre question
et dans ma réponse c'est que la France a
renoncé définitivement des cellucléaires
on a des manques les si tu Pacifique les
quatre autres pays enfin les trois
puisque les anglais sont besoin de faire
des saisiront Nevada les trois autres
pays ont conservé intacte leur moyen des
cellucléaires de tester des faire des
essais du cœur et en particulier dans le
vouliez si vous lisez le rapport des
rapports de congrès du Congrès américain
qui sont extrêmement détaillés vous
verrez dans leur dans le budget
américain est prévu chaque année la
préparation de la décès ducléaire au cas
où c'est un peu ce qu'a fait la France
en 92 avec le moratoire décidé par le
président Mitterrand on a continué à
préparer un essai nucléaire sans tirer
mais les Américains gardent cette
compétence là vivante bien entendu je
pense c'est un avis personnel le poids
politique sera tel je pense qu'ici à
museront pas mais cela dit tous les
autres pays dotés ont la possibilité de
réaliser ces nucléaires ce à quoi nous
nous avons définitivement renoncé
pour moteur M51 je ne connais pas
l'affaire c'est pas non plus dans mon
périmètre cela étant dit je pense que la
France est suffisamment
subtile et à droite pour avoir prévu les
clauses dans le pour qu'on continue à
faire les moteurs du M51 chez nous en
France
alors ce qui essaient de se doter
Pakistan Inde en réaliser des essais
nucléaires pareil ils ont pas renoncé
définitivement en faire par contre
pareil le poids politique sera tel que
la Corée du Nord a un site des
cellucléaires ils ont déjà réalisé 6
essais nucléaires le dernier en
septembre 2017 à forte énergie
si je lis la presse et si on regarde un
prêt spécialisé il serait en train de
préparer un septième essai nucléaire
donc clairement la Corée du Nord ou de
ce que l'on a vu des derniers essais de
notre point de vue et ils ont la
capacité à concevoir une arme nucléaire
évidemment une charge nucléaire
maintenant ils le feront probablement
pas seul
comment ferait-il l'Iran pour l'instant
sont engagés dans la dans le la première
étape de un pays proliférant c'est de
fabriquer de la matière nucléaire pour
réaliser les premiers engins
mais forcément un moment donné ça
passera par des phases de test
et Gisèle Jourdain
considérable secret pour personne en
particulier le quand regardent les
évaluations qui sont faites n'ont pas
par la dame mais par des chercheurs
indépendants et totalement donc
classifiés ils sont passés de 200 et
quelques têtes il y a 4 à 5 ans à 400 et
on annonce j'ai vu un article il y a pas
très longtemps là il serait plutôt aux
alentours de 500 aujourd'hui donc
clairement qu'en site jimping dit je
cherche à parité stratégique avec les
deux grands une manière de décoder ça je
vais avoir le même nombre d'armes
nucléaires que la Russie et lâcher et
les États-Unis bon le même nombre
nucléaire ce que déclare les deux pays
indépendamment du fait que Poutine s'est
retiré de newstart c'est 1550 armes
stratégiques bon donc la Chine est
plutôt dans cet esprit là
maintenant je sais pas ce que fera la
Chine avec des bandes nucléaires en
basse altitude il faut juste que vous
sachiez que la
navigation de nos missiles comme de
comme du reste que des têtes elles sont
c'est tout donc
voilà
Pierre Laurent
oui bonjour merci pour toutes vos
informations
ma question c'est
la LPM prévoit une augmentation
importante des crédits modernisation de
la dissuasion
le ministre nous a dit qu'il y a une
bosse budgétaire qu'est-ce qui explique
cette bosse budgétaire c'est-à-dire à
quoi vont précisément
qu'est-ce qui coûte le plus cher dans
l'augmentation etc j'ai une question
complémentaire c'est quelle est la
quelle est la durée de vie d'une arme
nucléaire vous avez dit que la dame
s'occupe de la conception a son
démantèlement
quelle est la durée de vie du d'une arme
nucléaire
la durée de vie d'une arme nucléaire
moderne c'est entre aux alentours de 20
25 ans durée de vie garantie par la dame
à sa mise en service
l'augmentation de crédit de la
dissuasion oui comme l'augmentation
globalement de la LPM si on compare la
LPM en cours llpm à venir bosse
budgétaire je sais pas vous répondre de
manière précise moi je vous ai dit tout
à l'heure la grille adulte c'est l'ordre
de 12,5% la dame là dedans c'est 30 à
35% pour ce qui concerne la dame on a on
est plutôt sur un on est plutôt sur une
grande stabilité de d'une loi d'une loi
de programmation militaire à une autre
et d'un pmlta un autre je voudrais
parler de notre outil budgétaire qui a
un plan moyen long terme sur 15 ans on
est relativement stable quand on regarde
sur les armes nucléaires à partir du
moment on est responsable de la
conception de l'architecture du
développement de la fabrication etc
finalement ce sont des des si on regarde
sur le très long terme ce sont des
budgets qui sont relativement constants
d'une année sur l'autre glob
sur la propulsion nucléaire et bien
l'augmentation des budgets de la dame et
périodique quand on a fabriqué de
nouveaux coeurs nucléaires de nouvelles
chaufferies nucléaires donc là on est
embarqué sur trois grands programmes de
renouvellement Barracuda sous un
nucléaire d'argent un troisième
génération et
porte-avion nouvelle génération la
chaufferie nucléaire n'est pas le prix
prétend des rangs d'un bateau donc
maintenant les grosses bosses puisque
vous avez parlé de boss vous avez
souvent un nucléaire lanceur de d'engins
3e génération sous-marin nucléaire je
vais pas vous donner le montant d'un
sous-marin français mais le problème
nucléaire
britannique qui vise à remplacer
sous-marin pour Kats sous-marin il sera
40 milliards de livres
nous on sera en dessous lors de grandeur
ça va être 25 à 30 milliards de d'euros
donc ça ça pèse le renouvellement des
composantes avec les missiles aussi bien
sûr l'air seul nucléaire quatrième
génération bien sûr donc on est rentré
dans une phase aujourd'hui on est en
train de renouveler les composantes et
en particulier la composante sous-marine
avec les sous-marins
je parle pas du SNA parce que le SNA est
aura grillé à nucléaire
merci enfin bruno Sido merci monsieur le
Président précisément je voulais vous
parler des SNLE tout le monde sait quand
il apparaît il suffit d'aller regarder
les familles faire du minou quand le
sous-marin passe le goulet de Brest et
ensuite il plonge au large on ne sait
plus où ils sont ils sont très furtifs
et les nouveaux que l'on va étudier sur
le seront encore plus seulement il se
dit que étant donné leur masse leur
poids leur masse il se dit qu'avec les
études sur la gravimétrie qui est
l'informatique quantique on demain on
pourra détecter ces anomalies
gravimétriques donc détecter les SN et
le et éventuellement les détruire alors
c'est pas dans votre complètement de
votre périmètre peut-être c'est
peut-être secret défense peut-être mais
si vous avez l'autorisation de répondre
et nous donner des précisions sur ce
sujet ce serait très agréable de votre
part
alors
je vous remercie pour votre question
sur les technologies de pointe et
technologie du futur que ce soit le
compte et quantique intelligence
artificielle ou autre on travaille bien
entendu dessus
pour l'instant le
sans être iconoclaste complètement on
est au démarrage du quantique on a
regardé nous de manière précise la
techno quantique pour le calcul pour
faire des calculateurs donc les fameux
qubits et
en fait sur nos opérations à nous et
quand on regarde la zoologie de nos
codes en cours à peu près 95% des
besoins tant de l'industrie que de la
recherche académique le quantique
aujourd'hui peut-être dans 20-30 ans je
sais pas ça ça va tellement vite mais
par contre aujourd'hui pour faire
tourner des codes comme les nôtres le
seul intérêt qu'on verrait à incubite
c'est le couplet à un général à un
microprocesseur généraliste qu'on
appelle un CPU et il servirait
d'accélérateur aujourd'hui on a beaucoup
de machines hybrides qui sont des
machines accélérées avec des CPU des GPU
GPU c'est les cartes graphiques c'est de
remplacer ces fameuses accélérateurs
carte graphique par des qubits par
contre si on regarde les détecteurs
quantiques puisque là on parle de
détection plutôt côté
il nous parait cette prometteur mais par
contre on avait décortiqué le fameux
article on parlait de ça c'est pareil
c'est c'est plusieurs décennies devant
nous mais pas une fois de plus faut pas
faire l'autruche ces techno là il faut
les évaluer il faut continuer à
travailler dessus moi j'ai des gens de
chez moi très sur le quantique et sur la
l'intelligence artificielle maintenant
est-ce que vous le dites vous-même entre
la première génération la deuxième et la
troisième on n'arrête pas d'améliorer la
discrétion du sous-marin donc un homme
averti en valant deux je vais le dire
comme ça les gens travaillent dessus et
je pense qu'on trouvera des parades
merci merci monsieur le directeur pour
cette audition tout à fait passionnante
qui nous fait mieux comprendre et mieux
saisir un petit peu à la fois les défis
que vous devez relever mais aussi
les avancées qui font que cette force de
dissuasion nucléaire française est notre
ultime ligne de défense et de protection
de notre territoire de notre
souveraineté je pense du reste je pense
que ce sera compliqué d'ici la fin de ce
mandat enfin qui sera utile à un moment
ou un autre que la Commission aille sur
l'un de ces sites pour voir comprendre
ce qui peut être mis à sa disposition en
tous les cas on vous remercie pour
l'ensemble de ces indications parce que
certaines étaient inconnues ou mal
comprise donc je crois que c'était bien
au moment où nous discutons de cette LPM
vous avez donné un pourcentage je pense
que ça correspond globalement d'après ce
que je bois à 50 milliards
12 et demi ça doit faire à peu près ça
donc c'est pas une somme négligeable
donc
c'est aussi ça relève aussi de la
compétence du Parlement de se faire une
idée précise
de ce de cette partie de la LPM merci
infiniment je vais vous raccompagner
mais je demande à nos collègues j'ai
deux trois informations à leur donner
ainsi que une désignation de rapporteur
merci à vous vous serez les bienvenus
sur un centre dames